and uh now magnus just advancing pawns
but
the king advances and uh
yeah so black's rook trying to cause him
okay well this was a a decision i did
not expect him to play at all
i kind of said it earlier you know you
kind of want to trade off rook
and knights but not necessarily rooks
and i feel that this
lighting game this is very
straightforward is it
yeah i mean i've won night end games
with three versus three on the same side
later than three versus one
okay so it is possible it is possible
and
magnus again his only hope is trading
off all of white's pawns unfortunately
that won't happen
all what he needs to do is make sure the
black knight doesn't get active just
walk the white king
the whole way around to the center that
should be
um should be game over magnus you can
still
see on his face okay this pawn push
slightly surprising
magnus just resigns though he knows he's
lost
he doesn't even try to defend him yeah
look at raj over there a big knot and we
have a smile from team aurora java that
is such
well an accomplishment in a must-win
situation he wins that final game and
that means
the match between these two the first
semi-final match it ties